So as a programming exercise, I want you to take this code
and tile both foo and bar using thread blocks that have 128 threads
and tiling, a tile size of 128 elements. Okay?
And as you'll see if you look at the code,
we've structured it so that it'll be safe for you to ignore the boundary effects
at the beginning and end of the arrays, the input and output arrays.
We're only calling this on a portion of the code in the middle of the array.
But of course you can't ignore the boundary effects
that happen at the boundaries between thread blocks.
So I'm looking for the percentage of time of the non-tiled version of the code
that your tiled version takes.
So for example, if your code ran exactly as fast as the non-tiled version,
then it would be 100% of the time,
and if your code ran twice as fast as the non-tiled version, then it would take 50% of the time.
Give me the percentage of time for both foo and bar after you've done the tiling.